Before we get stuck into Blueprints, let's discuss some terminology that might be useful
to help you get familiar with the concepts of Blueprints.
So in Unreal Engine, if you've not used any previous versions before, you can see
that a class is the highest type of template for anything that contains information.
So everything in Unreal is contained within a class.
Within a class, you can get objects.
This is the basis of all of the UE classes.
And it's a self-contained set of code, data, variables, essentially anything that holds
information such as functions, macros, these kind of things.
And then we have Actors in Unreal Engine.
And an Actor is a child class of an object.
And we'll go through a series of flow diagrams just to show you this flow of information.
But essentially Actors are all Unreal Engine specific.
They're things that define a special kind of object that can be placed in a level,
so they have X, Y, and Z coordinates.
They have properties that they can house.
You can have different Actor types like lights, cameras, meshes.
So if we just think about it from a kind of flow-based perspective, we start with
a class, we move to an object, and then an Actor is then what you would place inside the Editor.
So to give you a better idea about that description, if we think about an object,
Actors hold information, but they don't necessarily exist anywhere in the world.
They have this information that we spoke about before, they have the data that they
can execute, but they don't actually, they're not housed anywhere.
Whereas an Actor in Unreal Engine, the Actor thinks because it is based on an object,
so it has the properties of an object, and so an Actor can therefore say okay I exist
in the world, whether that be an X, Y, or Z coordinate in the Editor, through a camera,
a light, any of these Actor properties that we mentioned before.
And this is Unreal Engine concept for Unreal Engine 5, and it's been used in previous
Engines as well.
So if we think about the C++ terminology, parent classes in Unreal Engine, specific
classes that a child can inherit from.
So when we're talking about this flow of information, we're talking about having these
parent classes that hold the majority of the information, well maybe not the majority
of information, but all the core functionality that you would need within any child classes.
So it means that you don't have to rewrite code, you don't have to duplicate, a whole
bunch of information for things that you want had to have similar setups.
So in Unreal Engine, the main thing to take away here is that each parent class can
have many child classes.
And a child class inherits from this parent class, so you could refer to it as a subclass.
So when we're talking about the light example from the previous slide, when we're
talking about Actors in the level, parent class in this example would be the Point
Light Actor.
And therefore a Light Actor class is a child of the actor class.
And each child can only have a single parent class.
So you can't have this larger parent class and then create a child class from it.
And that child class has then multiple parents.
The easiest way to think about it is that each parent class can create many child
classes, so there's a flow, a downward flow of information from the main parent class.
And the child class can only have a single parent.
And what a parent class already contains is passed to the child.
So you can override this functionality inside the child class from the parent class, but
you can create information in the child class that then propagates up to the parent.
It's always a downward flow of information.
To give you an idea about this in a graph, we have the parent at the top, we have
a child class below, and you can still create these multiple child actors from the parent
class, however it doesn't work in the opposite direction.
And then to give you a deeper understanding more in the context of when we're making
games in Unreal Engine, all blueprint classes have a parent up until the object class,
which is a U object, which essentially stands for Unreal Object.
This is the origin class.
When you make a new blueprint, you must derive a child from an existing class.
So whenever you have a child class, it will always come from a previous class.
Object is the highest level and everything else comes from there.
So if we're talking about a character running through a scene, for example, you
can see the flow from, let's go from right to left here.
You start with this character classes.
You think, where did the character get its properties from?
Well in Unreal Engine, you have something called a Pawn, which has a bunch of these
properties that the child can inherit.
So with Pawn, you have Actor, which we referred to before.
The actor belongs in this 3D space, and the actor came from this larger object class.
And so that's essentially the class structure of how information flows, and it will help
give context to when you are creating your blueprints.
When we're talking about inheritance, in almost all aspects of its design, including
UE assets, there is some form of inheritance.
So using that previous example before from the character, the character inherited a whole
bunch of information that it prevents a duplication of information, and it just creates the communication
lines very clear in terms of where this came from.
So when we're opening blueprints up, say we open the character blueprint, for example,
still using this character example, you can see in the character blueprint that you can
go up through to the Pawn class, up through the Actor class, and into the Object class.
And we'll show this in more detail as we get into the course.